Hello.
Hi, Amanda.
What's up?
Nothing much.
I'm on the way home right now.
Are you?
Do you take the bus or subway?
I take both because my house is very far from my office.
How long does it take to get home?
It takes about an hour.
It is far!
I told you.
It's very tiring.
How about you?
It's very near my house.
I walk to my office every day.
I envy you.
Walking is good for your health.
I guess so.
By the way, don't you have a car?
I do, but I don't really drive much.
The traffic is terrible in the morning.
Can you avoid the rush hour?
It's just impossible.
One time, it took me three hours to get to the office!
That's not good.
When do you get up in the morning?
I usually get up at 5:30 am.
That early?
For what?
I work out in the morning.
That's how you stay so healthy!